[ __ ] this jungle juice jungle juice you
son of a [ __ ]
I can smell jungle juice I drank it I
love the fun I think it's great toss
dangerous dude yeah to me it was the
first thing I wanted to it I remember
making it and then drinking it and then
you don't remember much after that well
that's the whole problem is that it
tastes fine and then the next morning it
tastes like regret
[Music]
it's very this actually smells strong
[Music]
smells good Oh God
it smells like college like it's a
nostalgic smell all right Cheers cheers
mate it reminds me of ice luge's and
house parties it doesn't really taste
like alcohol frat houses with a sticky
floor like I can feel the sticky floor
like I'm underneath my feet and being
like why am I here it just tastes like
shrinking us actually it really reminds
me of a time when I hated alcohol and
now I understand why this not alcohol
like throughout the night people just
like spill jungle juice onto the carpet
and the rug guys I don't think yourself
I mean it's hard with these things
because it's like do I remember the
nights after drinking this and the
answer is no is there alcohol in your
stuff yeah this is definitely like
having one too many of these and get
like the late night pizza it's all a
familiar taste but I never really knew
what was in it well it takes a good
tease it okay then bad then fine and
then I forgot about it and wanted to try
together it tasted better than I
expected I really thought there was no
alcohol in it I still think there wasn't
enough Loki I might serve this at my
next social function so thank you for
reminding me college kids are onto
something and we should bring jungle
juice back okay I take this to go
chug Charlie I would pack with you and
every
[Music]